por eso
[Música]
parece que fuera una especie de déjà vú
pero en realidad y para muchos analistas
no lo es se trata de un nuevo escenario
no es una repetición es una nueva
coyuntura en la que la izquierda de
américa latina parece resurgir y pedir
una nueva oportunidad
esta nueva generación de gobiernos de
izquierda en la región a que responde
porque ese resurgimiento veamos algunos
datos desde el año 2018 estos son los
países los que han dado un viraje a la
izquierda en su espectro político méxico
argentina bolivia perú honduras chile y
recientemente colombia a este listado se
suman los ya países conocidos en el
vecindario cuba nicaragua y venezuela
que hacen parte de esa generación que
comenzó hace casi dos décadas y que ya
parece haberse renovado y bueno podemos
decir que cuba pues es la base de
referencia y de esa lucha de la
izquierda en américa latina y que está
enfrentando en este momento
manifestaciones y un malestar interno
allí en la la caribeña una de las
preguntas que hay es si brasil le va a
dar una nueva oportunidad a la izquierda
una izquierda con un nuevo aire pero con
un viejo conocido luiz inácio lula da
silva que aspira a un tercer mandato
como presidente de brasil las elecciones
que están previstas para el último
trimestre del año nos dirán qué rumbo va
a tomar ese país que es el motor
económico de américa latina
en que esa diferencia entonces esta
nueva generación de gobiernos de
izquierda a esa primera ola que hubo
hace prácticamente dos décadas en que se
diferencia el escenario político cuál es
el norte que tiene hay una conexión a
integración hay unión entre estos
gobiernos de izquierda de esta nueva
generación estas preguntas pues se las
vamos a hacer a nuestros invitados del
día de hoy para conversar sobre este
tema hemos invitado a maría dolores
gradolph o ella es doctora en ciencia
política también es directora del
observatorio electoral de la conferencia
perteneciente de partidos políticos de
américa latina y el caribe también es
docente universitaria de la universidad
nacional scalabrini ortiz y de la
universidad del salvador es miembro de
la asociación de estudios
internacionales de la república
argentina y desde la ciudad de san
salvador en el salvador se conecta luís
eduardo aguilar él es profesor del
departamento de sociología y ciencias
políticas de la uca en el salvador les
recuerdo que ustedes también hacen parte
de esta conversación pueden dejar sus
preguntas y comentarios en las redes
sociales estamos en twitter en instagram
y también en facebook en donde nos
encuentran como france24
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal la
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24 en
youtube también pueden seguir nuestra
señal en streaming y aprovecho para
saludar a las personas que están
escuchando nuestro podcast los invito
para que escuchen todos los contenidos
de nuestro programa que ya están
disponibles en app el podcast spotify
deezer y tuning
le doy la bienvenida entonces a maría
dolores gracias por estar con nosotros
en el programa maría dolores punto de
partida primera pregunta para conocer
posiciones de los invitados podemos
hablar entonces de un resurgimiento de
la izquierda una nueva oportunidad para
la izquierda latinoamericana bienvenida
hola muchas gracias santiago bueno un
placer estar con ustedes creo que vos
hacías mucho foco en esta nueva en esta
nueva izquierda anoche yo diría que es
un nuevo progresismo en américa latina y
que no tiene tanto que ver con aquel
jazz izquierdas de principios del siglo
de hace dos décadas en primer lugar
porque la coyuntura política regional y
mundial es bien distinta entonces creo
que desde ese punto de vista si bien
obviamente vos plantea vas a ir a las
continuidades por ejemplo en el caso de
bolivia luego del golpe de estado
vuelta del masa bolita pero también
hacía referencia al caso de argentina en
el caso específicamente también de lo
que puede llegar a suceder como un
regreso de lula en brasil dentro de
algún test de poquito tiempo las
elecciones del 2 de octubre me parece
que también estos estos nuevos
presidentes que rompen digamos porque no
efectivamente no son las izquierdas que
planteaban en aquel entonces lo vemos a
petro ahí en imagen ivory y
específicamente también andrés manuel
lópez obrador en méxico tiene que ver
principalmente con un contexto de donde
la ciudadanía se llamó a la calle y creo
que ese es el principal factor que
cambia y que pone el foco en esta idea
del cambio entre aquella izquierda de
principio de siglo y esta izquierda
cierta de abajo hacia arriba y con
grandes condicionantes del sistema
económico entonces
los contextos que se daban en aquel
entonces no son los mismos que se dan
ahora porque estos nuevos gobiernos
progresistas llegan al poder con grandes
expectativas de la ciudad pero con
grandes condicionantes en las
estructuras económicas que hacen que
esta tendencia entre las expectativas la
frustración ciudadana tener en grandes
desafíos valores ya vamos a profundizar
en esa coyuntura en ese momento político
y económico para diferenciarlo de esa
primera ola vamos a hablar de ese tema
le doy paso le doy palabra a luís
eduardo en la ciudad de san salvador-
bienvenido al programa punto de partida
luís eduardo se habla se puede hablar de
un resurgimiento de la izquierda de una
nueva oportunidad o como dice maría
dolores un nuevo progresismo
si es santiago muy buenos días a todos
los que escuchan este programa sin duda
es una coyuntura interesante porque
estábamos viendo la primera escuela por
decirlo así en la que la izquierda se
desarrolla en el poder venía muy llena
de idealismo de muchas consignas las
cuales no se lograron cumplir y de
alguna manera se transformaron en
muchas en prácticamente dictaduras el
caso de cuba venezuela nicaragua y ahora
pues luego de muchos gobiernos de
izquierda que llegaron y fracasaron y
luego la realidad se ha impuesto medidas
que de ajuste estructural que incluso
gobiernos de izquierda tuvieron que
implementar y sin duda ahora les obliga
a pensar una nueva forma de izquierda
desde el realismo es decir desde un
sistema que soy en sería mala palabra
para una izquierda tradicional que es un
sistema capitalista como implementar
políticas que ayuden a la población a
grandes grupos
electores que se encontraron
decepcionados con un sistema capitalista
que no les cumple ser un sistema
socialista que en el idealismo tampoco
ha logrado cumplir es decir desde ahora
esta nueva postura se plantean
posiciones híbridas que habrá que ver
con el tiempo en que decanta si en un
izquierdismo o una forma izquierda
progresista realista o un populismo
dictó dictadura que también es una
realidad que está en esas dos
posibilidades en el aire
la opinión de luis eduardo desde la
ciudad de san salvador continúo con
usted luis eduardo para hacer la ronda
en sentido contrario y le pregunto
entonces para que en conjunto con maría
dolores armemos el panorama de la
coyuntura política del momento que está
viviendo la región que ha llevado a este
resurgimiento de estos movimientos de
izquierda que han logrado catapultarse
hasta las hasta las presidencias de
algunos países ustedes ya han mencionado
algunos de los puntos clave quiero que
profundicemos entonces en ese en ese
tema coyuntura momento político qué es
lo que está pasando en la región qué
particularidades hay que le da con una
suerte de
impulso a estos movimientos de
izquierdas
sin dudas el hartazgo es una forma de
hacer política en la cual los partidos
muchas veces están siendo pues
descartados de las preferencias son de
las instituciones más desacreditadas en
cuanto a la opinión pública ahora y se
monta una izquierda no un movimiento
popular necesariamente si lo haremos de
forma global sino mucho en éste
personalismo en esta en esta forma de
entender la política como un mesías o un
un
salvador que me venga a cumplir todas
estas expectativas pero sin duda e
insisto en este punto algún peligro muy
grande con el populismo que puede venir
desde
es decir alguna especie de
transformación de que la ideología
pierde mucho valor en cuanto a los
electores y esta forma de representación
del personalismo se vuelve pues una
esperanza para la población pero que sin
duda puede generar una gran cantidad de
problemas y es que las instituciones se
sirven en diez pesos se vuelven débiles
a la hora de controlar estos
personalismo que se van desarrollando en
la red
-maría dolores su opinión sobre esta
pregunta sobre este tema
bueno en primer lugar yo creo que si uno
tiene consideración de lo que se
conceptualiza como populismo esto no
tiene que ver con una tendencia
ideológica vemos en brásil la forma de
conducción que ha tenido bolsonaro lo
hemos visto con donald trump en que
también en eeuu y claramente no es
digamos no son sinónimos las izquierdas
los progresismos el populismo entonces
creo que eso es un primer diferencial me
parece que esta idea que ha surgido
digamos éstos nuevos gobiernos
progresistas con una clara con un claro
llamado de las demandas ciudadanas
por un lado rompen con esa idea de los
personalismos y que cada vez más
presidentes que asumen al poder llaman a
la población a conducirse conjuntamente
en los petro lo decía muy claramente en
su discurso de asunción no sabemos
realmente cuáles son las respuestas
sabemos hacia dónde queremos ir pero
entre todos tenemos que construir ese
recorrido y creo que eso trata de romper
con las consignas personalistas en ese
sentido pero al mismo tiempo también y
veía ahí la imagen de de xiomara castró
en honduras parte también de una de una
idea de como la ciudadanía en
resistencia puede romper con un proceso
como ha sido por ejemplo los tantos años
de un gobierno luego del golpe de estado
en honduras y estos son los principales
desafíos no como lo vemos ahora muy
próximamente el 4 de septiembre con la
constituyente chilena cómo se organiza
esta ciudadanía que reclama
claramente por esa disrupción que se da
entre representantes y representados
donde claramente las instituciones
partidarias
se encuentran no aggiornadas a los
tiempos que la ciudadanía reclama pero
que obviamente esa participación
ciudadana necesita una conducción y creo
que ese es el gran desafío que hoy no se
encuentra como estos gobiernos
progresistas que llegan al poder pueden
conducir a esta ciudadanía que tiene
tantas expectativas con una promesa de
campaña que claramente choca con la
estructura económica que se ha dado de
varios años de gobiernos conservadores
en la región y con un contexto económico
región regional y mundial
aprieta mucho las economías
latinoamericanas claro maría dolores qué
característica particular se puede decir
que tiene esta ola qué característica
tiene yo sé que está en desarrollo y hay
gobiernos que están apenas comenzando y
es difícil poder evaluar y decir qué
tendencia o cómo fue el manejo o hacer
una evaluación de del
gobierno como tal pero usted ya podría
decir de pronto algunas características
particulares de esta segunda ola si se
le puede llamar una segunda ola y qué
tan cohesionada está esa izquierda en la
región entre países
bueno en primer lugar estas nuevas
izquierdas estos nuevos progresismo
surgen de contextos muy polarizados
cuando vemos las últimas procesos
electorales en la región vemos que la
mayoría de los presidentes presidentas
han llegado en los casos o con victorias
ajustadas o con segundas vueltas de por
medio y obviamente eso hace que genere
una tensión a la hora de pensar la
gobernabilidad sin ir más lejos no
hablamos es hasta recién del caso de
perú donde luego de una elección muy
polarizada con muchísima presión de
sectores de la derecha para no reconocer
la victoria de pedro castillo vemos
ahora las dificultades de gobernabilidad
que tiene un presidente que es uno toma
su electorado en la primera vuelta era
el 16 por ciento con una fragmentación
política muy grande entonces la
fragmentación política y la polarización
hace que estos gobiernos que llegan al
poder necesiten de generar muchísimos
mayores consensos para pensar la
gobernabilidad al mismo tiempo también
que tienen por un lado estás demandas
ciudadanas y las restricciones
económicas y por otro lado con la
segunda pregunta qué tiene que ver cuán
cohesionada está está estos nuevos
gobiernos creo que a diferencia así de
los procesos de la primera época del
siglo 21 de hace dos décadas donde las
instituciones de integración regional
tenían una fortaleza muy grande y luego
se fueron desintegrando los procesos de
integración las instituciones han
perdido su vigor y por eso creo tan
importante que para poder cuestionar la
política de estos gobiernos progresistas
en la región y también la política
regional incorporando otros gobiernos
que no tengan perfil progresista porque
claramente lo que uno ve hoy de estos
perfiles tiene que ver con el
pragmatismo necesario para poder llevar
adelante las políticas en una economía
tan globalizada
hay que pensar e institucionalizados en
los ámbitos de integración regional para
que tengan una perspectiva de futuro y
no para que sigan con sus venidas como
en los últimos años claro importante ese
punto luís eduardo en san salvador su
opinión que tanta cohesión hay entre
estos diferentes gobiernos y que
caracterizaría a usted como punto
destacado de esta segunda ola de
izquierda en américa latina'
me parece una pregunta muy compleja pero
sin duda es muy importante en el sentido
de que primero que hay una izquierda que
está bien consolidada que es la
izquierda en nicaragua o hay en
venezuela izquierda que ha ejercido el
poder pues mucho por el autoritarismo y
ha tenido sus avances y retrocesos pero
esta otra que podemos establecer como
una nueva izquierda por decirlo así como
una segunda ola que la podría enmarcar
en dos puntos uno con andrés manuel
lópez obrador en méjico o una figura
insisto en el caso de la izquierda y
personalista pero que tiene mucho
digamos conflicto con movimientos
sociales ambientalistas y que sin duda
no muestra una cohesión por esa figura
personalista que ejerce andrés manuel
pero si lo observamos por el otro polo
hay otra izquierda que se perfila menos
desde afuera y más institucionalista
menos personalista que es la de chile
un respeto mayor a las instituciones
incluso bien social habrá que ver cómo
se viene desarrollando esa juez
izquierda con el movimiento social y las
instituciones pero parece que viene una
construcción mucho más organizada mucho
menos está menguada mucho menos separada
y sin duda creo que en esos pueblos se
irán moviendo las izquierdas en el poder
y ojo que también creo que es importante
no solamente tomar en cuenta las
izquierdas que están en el poder sino
que hay algunos que han tomado el poder
en la izquierda y no han regresado o han
tenido una situación mucho más pues
menos favorecida ambientazo de bueno del
salvador que es donde yo estoy muy
probablemente la izquierda no vaya a
resurgir de una ex guerrilla porque la
gente ya llegó a su hartazgo no confía
ya la izquierda y sin duda también eso
muestra que los movimientos de
izquierdas tendrán que buscar nuevas
oportunidades en aquellos países donde
la gente ya no confía en ellos
luisa donde creo que es oportuno hacer
como una especie de evaluación y
análisis de los procesos electorales que
se han vivido en la región en los
últimos meses y en el último par de años
y es que cada vez importa menos o tal
vez parecería que es así que al votante
común le importa cada vez menos estas
ideologías de partidos y están más
concentrados en ver verdaderos
resultados porque ninguno de los dos
lados del espectro político ha dado esos
resultados o ha fomentado ese cambio
grande que esperan la ciudadanía de los
diferentes países de américa latina y
eso va mostrando una especie de
transformación de los sistemas políticos
de la forma de los votantes enfrentarse
a un proceso electoral que tan importa
si esto es una figura emblemática de un
espectro político del otro y más allá de
los ideales sino que lo que se quiere
ver son resultados porque ustedes lo
decían al principio la deuda sigue
siendo la misma la división social la
precariedad económica salarios bajos
la región sigue siendo poco en muchos
frentes si lo comparamos con otras
regiones del mundo
sí sin duda quisiera agregar algo más no
solamente que esta excepción hacia los
partidos la confianza en las
instituciones
esto hace que se fragmente en los
sistemas de partidos y son múltiples las
opciones políticas que se agregan y sin
duda hasta luego los personalismos pero
existe también esta situación de las
nuevas tecnologías de que de pronto
viene una coyuntura particular que hace
que un tema alto sobre todo en la
campaña y puede hacer que un candidato o
candidata logre de popularidad
instantánea a partir de estas olas o
shock mediático que logran suceder es
decir no solamente basta que una persona
sea consistente sino que en este en esta
crisis o colapso de los sistemas de
partidos hacen muy proclives que
situaciones coyunturales
logren pues
reformar
a consolidar un nuevo tipo de liderazgo
de la presidencia que sin duda tiene
efectos complicados en nuestra
democracia gente poco preparada gente
que tiene pues una formación política
muy baja pero que sin duda responde a
esta coyuntura
y con cómo de bueno como decía maría
viste no están ni de izquierda ni de
derecha esto es una situación que sucede
más allá de la ideología clara y maría
dolores su percepción sobre este tema su
opinión qué tanto pesa aquí la ideología
más allá de necesidad de cambios
necesidad de resultados contundentes
bueno en primer lugar yo creo que hay un
dato no mucho se habla incluso en
encuestas y en informes de que la
ciudadanía no valora la democracia y yo
creo que lo que no valora es este
sistema de gobierno este sistema
político que no le está dando respuestas
a sus demandas y cuando uno ve como la
ciudadanía va a votar y participar en
las elecciones claramente se da cuenta
que lo que está en discusión no es la
democracia sino digamos la canalización
de las políticas públicas entonces creo
que eso es un dato que la ciudadanía no
está enojada con la democracia y
participa activamente de la democracia
lo que sí está muy bien en imagen y
digamos si a la vez a la luz de todos es
que hoy por hoy lo que prima es la
política negativa entonces cuando se
piensa en un proceso electoral no solo a
través de las noticias falsas que cada
vez son más frecuentes y brutos los
órganos electorales han tenido que
invertir y trabajar muchísimo para
rebatir las noticias falsas en contextos
electorales sino que al mismo tiempo
también las opciones de los ciudadanos
terminan siendo en contra y no a favor
de una opción política y obviamente eso
va ligado a lo que os preguntaba no de
si efectivamente hay un programa de
gobierno hay una ideología detrás
claramente lo que hay detrás es un
hartazgo de cierto de cierta forma de
hacer política y por lo tanto como esa
política negativa se canaliza pero sí
creo que algo que sí es importante y con
respecto a las nuevas formas de hacer
política y a las redes sociales que eso
también va en contra de las
institucionalidades no o sea hablábamos
recién de estos líderes populistas y
claramente lo puedo también focal
maría dolores creo que perdimos la
conexión con nuestra invitada voy a
seguir entonces conversando con luis
eduardo en la ciudad de san salvador y
ya vamos a retomar la conexión con maria
dolores luís eduardo está
mirando entre mis notas un punto
importante para analizar también es la
visión de los mandatarios en esa primera
ola la visión era una necesidad de
integración una necesidad de cortar esos
lazos con eeuu que ha sido el país que
mayor influencia política y económica ha
tenido en la región había una necesidad
también de aprovechar ese boom petrolero
y el boom de commodities en la región
para respaldar otros movimientos
similares en otros países para poder que
se movieran en bloque cuál es la visión
ahora de los mandatarios que tenemos en
el poder hay necesidades ustedes ya lo
decían muy distintas por ejemplo el tema
medioambiental ahora parece ser una
prioridad para muchos de los gobiernos
de turno y no está no está dentro de esa
visión tenerse que desligar por completo
de países como eeuu o tener se que aliar
con otros actores internacionales como
la ira en rusia tal vez el apuesta por
algo un poco más multipolar y vemos el
caso de méxico que tiene una buena
relación con eeuu
y sin duda lo que se va desarrollando es
una especie de pragmatismo político
incluso muchos en ciencia política se
plantean si es el fin de las ideologías
el pragmatismo hace que se evalúen
ciertos problemas de políticas públicas
e incluso de popularidad
sociales y en torno a eso se va moviendo
mucha de la política que se va
desarrollando en torno a esto puedo
incluso citar países que pueden tener
muy buena relación con china y muy buena
relación con eeuu pero lo que les
interesa son resolver problemas y en
esta parte retomando lo que dije al
principio en esta parte pura o jurista
idealista de la primera ola como se ha
denominado en esta entrevista de la
izquierda en latinoamérica pues dijo
muchas lecciones y una de ellas es no
poder o no únicamente depender de una
sola potencia sino buscar el pragmatismo
político buscar aliados de acuerdo con
durán y problemas muy particulares y
creo que muchos de estos gobiernos de
izquierdas lo están entendiendo
importante ese punto maría dolores
retomamos la conexión con usted allí en
argentina estamos hablando de la visión
de los mandatarios y las prioridades en
las agendas y luis fernando toca un tema
importante y es la ideología que también
lo veníamos desarrollando y hay un
concepto que no sé qué opinión tengan
ustedes este esto es socialismo del
siglo 21 que fue precisamente acuñado
por allá a principios de la década del
2000 muy usado por hugo chávez a partir
del 2005 sobre esta nueva ola que
comenzaba en américa latina' podemos
hablar de un nuevo socialismo del siglo
21 en la instancia en la que estamos o
esto ya pasa a ser parte de la historia
política de la región y estamos en un
nuevo capítulo
creo que básicamente si estamos en un
nuevo capítulo claramente los conceptos
que bueno que por ahí se pensaban en
aquel momento no son los mismos
principalmente porque
retomando un poco lo que se planteaba
recién los gobiernos latinoamericanos
tienen una necesidad de un pragmatismo
político pero solo
dolores seguimos teniendo problemas con
esa conexión retomamos la conversación
con luis eduardo luís eduardo su opinión
que era justamente la pregunta que le
iba a ser después de maría dolores
conocer su opinión sobre este concepto
del socialismo del siglo 21 en la región
de américa latina qué opinión tiene
usted
y sin duda fue una consigna muy
interesante desarrollada por hugo chávez
y en esto montada sobre una estructura
de su figura sobre petróleo sobre la
transformación
de la vida de grandes mayorías pero sin
duda hoy la página se ha se ha pasado
ahora se tiene que pensar en unas nuevas
formas de izquierda y de hecho no es
primera vez que se hace las izquierdas
han tenido estas características no
todas incluso dentro de los mismos
países se han concentrado en una sola
manera de desarrollar políticas quizás
hay unos consensos generales como que el
estado toma el centro o el control que
se desarrollan las políticas sociales
este que se
impulse a recolectar más impuestos pero
habrán bemoles ahora habrán cambios que
sin duda dejarán en la categoría de
socialismo del siglo 21 que aparece
incluso bueno cuando su uso por todo el
cambio demográfico
a las redes sociales y esto es un
mediático sin duda van transformándose y
van exigiendo nuevos nuevos nuevos
modelos de construcción social y el
socialismo del siglo 21 pues ya no
responde a ese modelo maría dolores no
sé si usted coincide en que vemos a una
sociedad un poco más empoderada tal vez
en argentina en el país donde usted está
es más habitual que los ciudadanos
salgan a las calles a exigir a protestar
a reclamarle al gobierno es algo
habitual en la sociedad argentina pero
en otros países de américa latina no era
así citó el caso de colombia donde
siempre se vio la protesta como algo
típico de gente inconforme con el
gobierno pero que era precisamente de
izquierdas o personas que eran que eran
cercanas a los pensamientos de las
guerrillas de izquierda del país y era
mal visto socialmente salir a
manifestarse a las calles ese concepto
ha cambiado en colombia lo demostró así
el estallido social que vivió el
presidente duque esto me lleva a la
siguiente pregunta y es que tan activa
entonces está la sociedad ahora
precisamente para hacer garantizar las
reglas de la democracia para estos
gobiernos de izquierda porque lo
pregunto porque veíamos a presidentes
como chávez en su momento como evo
morales que a raíz de este boom
económico que tenían sus países tenían
libertad para hacer movimientos y
campañas para modificar la constitución
y quedarse en el gobierno por un periodo
presidencial más ya vimos lo que le
costó a evo morales e intentar
reelegirse en bolivia
hubo muchas críticas precisamente por
ese referendo que él perdió y que él
pasó por alto el resultado de ser
referente y sin embargo fue a unas
elecciones que fueron muy controvertidas
que tan activa hasta la ciudadanía
yo creo que la ciudadanía está muy
activa y solo dio en cuenta obviamente
el caso que citaba en el caso de
colombia de cómo los jóvenes sobre todo
los jóvenes de los centros urbanos
aquellos jóvenes que no habían tenido la
posibilidad de estar en las
universidades y que realmente en el
contexto no sólo de la historia del
conflicto armado sino de las grandes
desigualdades hizo que se pongan en la
primera línea en el protestando en
contra de esa estructura político
económica institucional y policial
también en chile en una sociedad que
incluso ya desde el 2009 los estudiantes
salían a las calles en un contexto de un
gobierno progresista como era el de la
concertación en de michelle bachelet
también en perú se empezó a hablar por
primera vez de pensar una reforma
constitucional en una en una sociedad
muy concentrada en una sociedad muy
conservadora entonces creo que la agenda
de los jóvenes que es bien distinta
en la de los jóvenes de décadas
anteriores no es una agenda ideológica
sino que es una agenda temática uno
cuando ve cuáles son las consignas de
los jóvenes tiene que ver con las
cuestiones medioambientales tienen que
ver con el acceso al trabajo tiene que
ver obviamente a la posibilidad de no
tener que endeudarse para poder estudiar
y eso es algo que en colombia se vio que
en chile se vio que en perú se vio que
también generó la posibilidad de una
resistencia en honduras y de un triunfo
del gobierno de xiomara castró y que
creo que interpela hoy a los partidos
políticos y a la dirigencia que no está
conectada con ese tipo de diálogo no son
los partidos políticos mucho más
conectados con poder dialogar desde el
punto de vista doctrinario y son estos
jóvenes son las mujeres son las minorías
son los migrantes la movilidad humana en
américa latina es un tema central y que
hace que las ideologías sean
transnacionales principalmente porque
los temas de agenda estas comunidades
son transnacionales así que creo que hay
muchos desafíos creo que la ciudadanía
está en por edad creo que al mismo
tiempo es necesario que los sistemas
políticos se adapten a poder pensar
nuevas instancias de participación
institucionalizada que no sea
simplemente la elección cada dos cada
cuatro cada cinco años de acuerdo a cada
una de los sistemas electorales me
parece que se requieren de nuevos
espacios y es la ciudadanía la que no
está reclamando en eso sí que hay
sintonía en la región de américa latina
que se caracteriza por no estar unida en
muchos aspectos pero los reclamos de la
ciudadanía tal parece que tiene muchos
aspectos en común llegó a los últimos
minutos ya del programa y quiero
preguntarles a modo de conclusión y
comienzo entonces con luís eduardo en
san salvador- preguntándole qué tanto
puede durar esta ola ya lo decíamos
estos gobiernos de la ola anterior
hicieron modificaciones a las
constituciones para poder quedarse en el
poder estar dos períodos continuos tres
períodos consecutivos y luego
posteriormente pues tuvieron que salir
y entregarle el bastón a otra persona en
el caso de venezuela chávez se lo pasó a
maduro pero en el caso en el que estamos
en este momento que tanto puede durar
esta siguiente ola luís eduardo
bueno eso es una excelente pregunta con
una incógnita
a la base y me quiero quizás terminar
con esto para
juntarlo con la pregunta anterior que
tanto está participando la gente bueno
estamos hablando de américa latina
preguntemos a los venezolanos los
nicaragüenses este los cubanos que tanto
han logrado mantener una posición de
crítica a un gobierno que sin duda ha
hecho una
una continuidad en el poder y eso es
peligroso para una democracia sin duda
no se puede llamar democracia cuando no
hay espacios de crítica o cuando los
espacios de crítica se reducen y esos
tres países en ese caso y hay que
tomarlos en cuenta para analizar esto de
la participación ciudadana cuánto va a
durar esta ola pues depende del
planteamiento que había hecho el inicio
de cuál sea el rumbo que tome si sea el
rumbo para construir una
institucionalidad más fuerte y si es por
ahí muy probablemente vayan a competir
en elecciones y vaya a favorecer mucho
la institucionalidad de los países o
pueden tomar el otro camino que sin duda
es el que ya hemos visto en los tres
casos anteriores que estuvimos
mencionado si en esos tres casos queda
en evidencia que tener una institución
electoral una entidad electoral y tener
una periodicidad en las elecciones no
garantiza la democracia es necesario
que haya también una alternancia en el
poder en algunos de los casos que es lo
que no ha sucedido precisamente en esos
en esos países y es justo está viviendo
colombia en este momento una alternancia
en el poder que no se había visto
tampoco desde el lado de la derecha que
históricamente ha gobernado colombia
maría dolores su conclusión para el
cierre del programa
bueno coincido y agradezco obviamente la
invitación que es una pregunta que
todavía no nos genera la incógnita pero
creo que sí es importante pensar porque
llegaron estos gobiernos progresistas a
la región y creo que en principio tiene
que ver con que muchos de los derechos
que había ampliado y garantizado esa
primera ola de gobiernos progresistas
socialistas nacionales populares de la
primera década del siglo 20 tuvieron una
retracción en derechos en los últimos
años de gobiernos conservadores que des
institucionalizaron las procesos de
integración en la región entonces creo
que esta historia reciente hace que
estos gobiernos progresistas tengan
muchísima expectativa por parte de la
ciudadanía claramente va a depender
mucho de cómo pueden estos gobiernos
progresistas vincularse y tender puentes
con la ciudadanía para que esas demandas
y es el porqué llegaron se ha legitimado
por estas mayorías que se han adoptado
por estas opciones progresistas en la
región y pueda entender por ahí incluso
a nuevas formas de progresivos nuevas
formas de socialismo nuevas formas de
izquierda que no tiene que ver
simplemente con volver a ciclos de
derecha en la región sino con nuevos
nuevas formas de gobierno que tengan una
sociedad mucho más activa y un sector
público un sector social del tercer
sector más fuerte pues a maría dolores
ya luis eduardo les agradezco mucho por
haber hecho este análisis para la
audiencia de france 24 nos queda
pendiente el caso de brasil cualquier
cosa puede pasar en esas elecciones
presidenciales de ser así entonces sigan
a luís inácio lula da silva para ese
tercer mandato en la presidencia las
siete naciones más pobladas de américa
latina y las seis mayores economías de
la región estarían en manos de gobiernos
de izquierda y ya veríamos cómo se
configura de pronto ese proceso de
integración regional entre estos países
lo vamos a ir siguiendo la lupa aquí en
el debate de france 24 muchísimas
gracias por la sintonía pueden seguir
con france 24
[Música]